canadian lex brakovsky is embarking on a
dangerous journey packing this van full
of supplies from baby food to body armor
and driving it to the front lines in
ukraine watching it from from my home in
canada was just driving me nuts like it
was hard to
to watch it and not do anything about it
six weeks ago brakovsky was here on his
boat in nova scotia the lobster
fisherman moved to canada 30 years ago
but grew up in ukraine within days of
russia's invasion he flew to poland and
met a local aid group looking for
drivers willing to travel to the front
lines they need people that are willing
to go more than they need money i think
because there isn't too many people that
that are
you know ready to to drive to places
like that and for good reason last month
berkowski delivered aid to this city
near the russian border he then filled
his van with women and children and was
driving them out when his vehicle came
under attack all we've seen is just
explosions right right right in front of
us he and hundreds of others were
trapped he spoke to global news from
their shelter we tried to get out three
times yesterday but every time we get we
get anywheres or
right away under constant shelling
there's absolutely no power no heat
no
very limited water supply finally after
five days of failed attempts he managed
to escape
back to the relative safety of levive in
western ukraine after a few hours of
sleep he headed back to the front lines
with another shipment of aid we need
this help an adviser to the ukrainian
president had this message for other
ukrainian canadians for the many leaders
of the ukrainian
diaspora in canada
maybe it's time to come to ukraine
global news met many canadians answering
that call from the ukrainian government
from all walks of life i was actually
in a way pleasantly surprised
that so many canadians have have come
here this canadian ukrainian
entrepreneur is now handling logistics
and procurement for ukraine's volunteer
defense forces this millwright from bc
isn't even ukrainian but he's taking six
weeks unpaid leave to deliver aid and
rescue civilians these people have been
fighting the further democracy and i
just couldn't stand for the russians to
come back and take that all away from
them ottawa is advising canadians to
avoid all travel to ukraine but these
volunteers say staying home wasn't an
option
jeff semple global news toronto